[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment et les apps tout
alors aujourd'hui on est au guillaume
saint pol guillaume c'est pas mon pote
c'est bien lieu dit de la réunion alors
on va retrouver jean marie on est dans
son jus qui s'appelle l'eucalyptus
je sens qu'on va bien manger je sens le
bon tikkari feu de bois
je sens le bon petit dessert de toute
façon comme d'habitude allez venez avec
moi veut neymar mal
[Musique]
en
dans un
eh bien
au monde
pâlit jamais
il est là jean marie quand même alors
nous va faire qu'on me donne la réunion
lontan la connais ma personne
jean marc riboud à assembler
[Musique]
le saignement
construit sous la terre
comme si ça n'était
mais c'est son mari mangeurs qu'aubry
l'émission est bel et bien et bien
revient à oui ça va bien merci d'accueil
a touché au moins vingt ans alors là me
vois que c'est une grande propriété
khulna par contre un petit peu très vite
autre activité à la nature et des freins
tirana pour le titre l'un dit d'accord à
bourges il d'ailleurs fait un peu
marcher un peu des trois petits animaux
evènement nous proposons en affirmant on
va voir les animaux
[Musique]
apa
c'est tout le temps
en fait non
l'expérimenté et
[Musique]
ça nous les exactement à quel endroit
nous les la fin d'année où guillaume
apple palm os palm hills onu sida au
cameroun c'est le mieux pour manger et
diamants un petit coup vite pour moi
savoir mais un peu curieux fait combien
de temps vont vite sur les hommes et 28
ans 28 ans que j'habite ici et ça
conserve sa conseil conservent le
bonhomme
mon chemin
et pour l'heure que beaucoup marqué la
télé week-end et 4 5 6 et non ça c'est
pour la table capot la table la nuit on
n'a pas un stade neuf pourrait toujours
combien bataille pas la thaïlande et de
la vie est belle bagarre ces parcs et je
me dis que roi mage deuxième de la même
à huy pour de la zone et où le refus
d'entrée vieux maintenant vraiment je
pense à la normale la viande mais bon
[Musique]
fenice savait déjà que les affaires
marchent bien au ballon
tout va bien
[Musique]
m
oh non
jouer dix cochons la banque et des mails
10.24 pour maintenant le lapin bref
voilà belle petite firme qu'il faut pour
le bon petit gîte qu'il faut
qu'aujourd'hui où c'est exactement ça
creuse en corrèze et elle a encore de la
marge
le type de vin rouge
petite femme n'était
à cause de quoi
ce rapport
m
le boulet
alors où seront mis la main sur les
lapins le cochon les pintades les poules
coqs le cabri ses larges de jean marie
c'est plus large de nos essais large
dans ma vie après las d'être arabe est
l'un des trois boeufs aussi ce qui se
passe là me vois aussi de jolis rech oui
que les alarmes des tanks à cette année
à pâques ou deux tonnes de pêches pour
cette année un vent trop favorable 2,3
alors les biquettes comment ça se passe
et ça l'est pour la table aux six ans
plus tard ça c'est en masse à laisser
comme ça on va aller
[Musique]
alors je sens que la pluie va bientôt
arriver un ont prévalu télé et c'était
la bonne médias en même temps on est
dans les eaux
c'est la saison alors plein dans le moi
qu'il faut et la pluie tombe et c'est
comme ça je me dis là namouchi séries
dominées qu'elle freine c'est un
adversaire
on va bientôt euros par an donc on est
invité à un anniversaire aujourd'hui à
oui l on est invité à un anniversaire
aujourd'hui des noms mais est-ce que
c'est pas magnifique tout ça moi j'adore
jean-marie mis m
[Musique]
on peut pousser un peu tout le temps
tout s'est dit c'est apologistes et puis
ça bat la poire ou à bacau on en a pris
aussi we show blue
on nous dit je veux boire balle à avoir
un hautbois de cheveux ben c'est me jill
habana du mois comme sa petite salle à
deux ans et ralph bundi salade le chou
est bon tout ça où tu chéris lambda d'un
thé notamment la allons voir ça là pour
les choux
[Musique]
la veille il avait maintenant quoi
et fait tomber dedans on travaille à
temps les quatre ans darko avoir lavé
grandin et à vous arrêter l'épisode 126
travail j'ai arrêté
on voit un moment donné où furent tiji
tuna aux animaux tu es là on en a aux
légumes t elle à la vie est belle
notamment le chou dans lire comme un
bruit sourd aux gars ça comment les
jolies ou
[Musique]
chou rouge route vers midi au pkk
utilise abou koné une salade comme ça
pour combien de personnes nous couvrons
à combien de chevaux préparer à une
nouvelle guerre dans une dizaine de
personnes attrapent au même moment à la
mode de chez nous
[Musique]
dans les faits si montaigne opérateurs
monfils et clément demers d'accord pour
le moment reçu en même temps parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de blues est ce que le
suisse lui aussi beaucoup gêné que le
papa ah oui un bon là me présenterai mon
fils dominique jour en janvier dominique
de même ça va bien ça va
paraît que je suis certaine exercer en
effet que tu as vingt ans un petit peu
plus 35 27 30 55 t béthune il fait
passer à 25 ans et mesdames vous voyez
gentil si les faits c'est un méchant
alors je marie dominique diamanti coup
coup et ça cela préparer toulouse midi
la carie chaque année jacques où loulou
l'eau ils fument encore non
en bon état et encore iportal souvent le
fait qu harry deux carry chaque repas
d'abord face aux suisses si nani mange
pas quelque chose d'immense date d'arrêt
complet de boucane et saucisse mais
c'est vrai que le plus souvent c'est
carry poulet
elle s'était poisson au gaz 6 à
tradition qu il a obéi boucané et ça a
pris deux chars et cary kochman au match
aller voter c'est qu'ils jouent au pied
fait pas lourd vole pas
[Musique]
on est bien servi la non retrouve à nous
avec josy ce pur cela mais comment lieu
magnifique les gens quels qu'ils
arrivent et disent on est dans un
endroit parade paradisiaque d'accord
avec les parce qu'on a voulu partager
cet endroit avec eux mais cet endroit où
vous êtes là il faut donc la cuisine on
voit on voyage on fait voir et puis
après quelques fois il utilise cet
endroit là comme la piste de danse
figurez vous d'accord
et aussi mais quand vous avez des tas
mais à seulement j'y prenne le titre de
petit déjeuner ils font ce qu'ils
veulent quand ils viennent au gîte de
badgeage anniversaire et puis ben bon
appétit désolé désolé mais là à un monde
ne peut plus attendre pas bisous
xinhua dans la rue les gens me
demandaient
[Musique]
l'art aux attentes
ben écoute après le repas donc l'un
d'eux sous l'eau sous un magnifique
kiosque au milieu d'un monde est plutôt
mejia on a eu l'idée de faire ce
qu'elles sont en bois dans la forêt puis
une petite forêt que les taux mais y'a
juste à côté donc pour pas dénaturer
justement le site et en même temps 5
heures ce qui permet aux gens de pouvoir
redécouvrir la nature est sous cette
forêt à demain il y aura un projet c'est
de faire de planter des arbres
endémiques pour que les gens puissent
redécouvrir en même temps dis moi tu es
originaire de de guillaume en fait avec
la famille on habitait au port d'abord
d'accord donc
quand j'ai eu dix ans on a déménagé on
est venu ici parce que mon père ait
l'opportunité trouvé ce terrain pour le
cultiver donc ce qui n'était pas
agriculteur à l'époque il était
commerçant donc il a fait une
réorientation dans l'agriculture et donc
c'est depuis dix ans qu'on est là
bon le gîte a pris du temps quand même
être construit parce que on l'a on l'a
fabriqué sur fonds propres en fait au
début donc on a commencé la construction
en 2006 pour terminer l'année dernière
donc en 2015 mais c'est un projet
typiquement familiale puisque toute la
famille a participé donc les ongs
formats sont donc ils ont aidé à la
construction dont du gîte mam
et puis mon à passer par les entreprises
pour finaliser les travaux combien de
personnes tu peux accueillir ici comment
ça se passe
week-end semaine réservation 10 mois
tout s'il te plaît alors le gîte bon et
calyptus maïdo comme ça donc qui jouent
derrière donc ce
contient huit chambres d'amis chambre
avec des lits doubles donc les gens qui
viennent au gîte bon déjà dispose donc
des kiosques pour pouvoir se divertir la
forêt pour faire les malades et ensuite
sur place même on a des vélos cas des
vélos mis à disposition
on a mis un jacuzzi aussi des
dispositions qui peuvent se prélasser
dans un jacuzzi chauffer 1 40 degrés
même si on lui donne l'auteur y fait
frais ça fait sensation miraculeuse
terry et ensuite on a créé des
partenariats aussi avec donc les acteurs
locaux puisque il faut travailler en
réseau et faire développer l'économie
locale donc que les gens qui dorment au
gîte ont des tarifs négociés auprès de
prestataires comme le relais du maïdo le
centre équestre ou encore les descentes
en vtt seller se quitter je te dis au
revoir merci pour l'accueil madérien à
la prochaine avoir bonne journée et ben
moi je redescends d'un débat c'est
dommage on ne dit rien j'ai mal au coeur
[Musique]
alors je vous rappelle un petit peu
l'adresse 1 l'eucalyptus guillaume dans
les eaux faudra remonter un peu si
jean-marie il faut venir
jean-marie les terribles sa famille elle
est terrible alors on en a profité pour
s'arrêter devant la bombe posée pour
faire un petit au revoir
1 un petit au revoir bien amical 1 et
mais alors on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge mais alors pas du tout
[Musique]